das ist eine wirklich erstaunliche
entdeckung die jetzt us-forscher gemacht
haben die großen vier kräfte der physik
bestimmen das universum und damit auch
unsere existenz doch fest steht manche
interaktion im kosmos sind mit diesen
vier kräften nicht zu erklären eine
mysteriöse bislang unbekannte und
unentdeckte fünfte kraft die eng mit der
dunkle materie verknüpft sein könnte
wollen us wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler nun mit der hilfe eines
neutronenstrahlung aufspüren und schon
jetzt haben sie etwas absolut
verblüffendes im inneren von atom
entdeckt klicks um saint lucia gegen es
dreimal pro woche spannende science wie
das abonniert den kanal und aktiv wird
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los ganz
herzlich willkommen kommt zu den bislang
vier bekannten kräften der physik schon
bald eine fünfte kraft dazu zu den
fundamentalen kräften gehören die
elektromagnetische wechselwirkung die
gravitation sowie die starke und
schwache wechselwirkung viele prozesse
die auf der erde und im weltall
vonstatten gehen können wir tatsächlich
auch mit diesen vier kräften der physik
erklären doch sobald die dunkle materie
ins spiel kommt muss die physik mit dem
bisherigen erklärt modellen passt und
klar ist bislang nur dass das aufspüren
einer fünften fundamentale kraft der
physik eine echte sensation und ein
wendepunkt für die teilchenphysik wäre
solch eine entdeckung hätte das
potenzial das verständnis des universums
und der dort herrschenden kräfte
komplett zu verändert und auch der
geheimnisvollen dunklen materie könnte
man so endlich auf die schliche kommen
so die hoffnung zahlreicher fachleute
weltweit doch bislang steht der
endgültige beweis noch aus und das
bereitet forschungsteams weltweit
schlaflose nächte die existenz einer
solchen fünften kraft konnte trotz
intensiver forschung bislang noch nicht
belegt werden doch genau das könnte sich
jetzt ändern denn ein internationales
forschungsteam ist dieser fünften kraft
auf der spur und zwar mit der hilfe
einer neuen methode die rede ist von
neutronen strahlen mit deren hilfe
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
nun die kristallstruktur von silizium so
präzise wie noch nie zuvor
untersuchungen konnten die aktuellen
ergebnisse sind deutlich detaillierter
als alle bisherigen analysen die auf der
basis von röntgen techniken
funktionierten alle spannende infos zu
diesem thema gibt es jetzt hier bei
pixum science in future bisher konnten
physik teams weltweit insgesamt vier
natürliche kräfte bestätigen das ist zum
einen die elektromagnetische kraft die
moleküle und atome zusammenhält dann
natürlich noch die gravitation die
planeten auf ihren bahnen und außerdem
auch die galaxien selbst zusammenhält
hinzu kommen noch zwei nuklearer
wechselwirkung nämlich die so genannte
starke kernkraft und die schwache
kernkraft die beide auf ebene der
atomkerne eine entscheidende rolle
spielen doch das standardmodell der
physik ist wohl eine unvollständige
erklärung dafür wie die natur
funktioniert höchstwahrscheinlich ist
das universum mehr als es die theorie
bisher beschreibt ein internationales
forschungsteam ist dieser bisher
unentdeckten mysteriösen fünfter kraft
auf der spur verwendet wurden bei der
aktuellen analyse neutronen strahlen mit
deren hilfe ein silizium kristall
genauer ins visier genommen wurde dazu
sagt einer der beteiligten
wissenschaftler albert young das
großartige an dieser arbeit ist nicht
nur die präzision wir können uns auf
spezifische beobachtungen im kristall
konzentrieren sondern auch dass wir dies
mit einem tisch experiment und nicht mit
einem großen chorleiter tun können mit
diesen kleinen präzisen messungen
könnten wir fortschritte bei einigen der
schwierigsten fragen der
grundlagenphysik erzählen die neue
methode könnte also schon in der nahen
zukunft unsere suche nach neuen kräften
der physik vereinfachen in ihrem
aktuellen experiment führten die
fachleute eine sogenannte pendelt lösung
interferometrie durch dabei handelt es
sich um ein optisches verfahren mit dem
kristalline materialeigenschaften
bestimmt werden können unter anderem
seine thermischen und mechanischen
eigenschaften aber eben auch die
anordnung der kräfte die die atome im
material zusammen halten dafür wird eine
neutronenstrahlung auf ein silizium
kristall geschossen dazu sagt der
physiker albert young der an dem projekt
beteiligt war obwohl silizium
allgegenwärtig ist lernen wir immer noch
etwas über seinen grundlegendsten
eigenschaft neutronen eignen sich dafür
hervorragend da sie nicht besonders mit
den elektronen im inneren das materials
wechselwirkung dagegen bringen
röntgenstrahlen aufgrund ihrer
wechselwirkung mit elektronen einige
nachteile bei der messung atomarer
kräfte in einem material mit sich
bislang wurden solche untersuchungen an
kristallstrukturen hauptsächlich mit
röntgenstrahlen durchgeführt somit
können dann die winkel intensitäten und
muster des strahls erfasst werden wenn
er durch die ebenen tritt oder von ihnen
abprallt doch eine neutronenstrahlung
deutlich weniger empfindlich gegenüber
der elektronendichte und den schwingungs
eigenschaften des silizium kristalls die
kristalle können damit deutlich
detaillierter untersucht werden dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam unsere
messungen sind unter anderem deshalb so
empfiehlt sich weil neutronen viel
tiefer in den kristall eindringen als
röntgenstrahlen ein zentimeter oder mehr
und damit eine viel größere anordnung
von sternen messen das internationale
forschungsteam untersuchte bei seinem
aktuellen experiment einen sogenannten
perfekten siliziumkristallen wir sind
alle atomanlagen in jeder ebene
identisch und die ausrichtung und
abstände im gesamten kristall
wiederholen sich immer wieder die
neutronen die in den kristall gelangen
wechselwirken mit diesen ebenen als
welle und der neutronenstrahlung wird
wiederholt von den kristall leben
reflektiert die reflektierenden wellen
kodieren letztendlich diese
wechselwirkung und wenn die welle dann
aus dem kristall entweicht können die
fachleute aus der abprall historie
wichtige rückschlüsse ziehen zum
beispiel wie man sich die anordnung im
kristall genau vorstellen kann und wie
dadurch die neutronen beeinflusst werden
wichtig hierbei ist dass der
siliziumkristallen sehr genau
ausgerichtet wird zudem wurde er dann um
seine senkrechte achse gedreht um so
einen wellenmuster zu erzeugen so gelang
es den wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern eine einzigartige
momentaufnahme zu schaffen diese daten
ermöglichen es den fachleuten die kräfte
im inneren des kristalls sehr genau zu
verstehen einige kleine veränderungen im
experiment führten dazu dass die
genauigkeit um den faktor 4 nochmal
verbessert werden konnte die rede ist
von den so genannten bric bedingungen
demnach wird eine elektromagnetische
welle mit einer bestimmten wellenlänge
von einem solchen kristall nur dann
reflektiert wenn sie unter ganz
bestimmten winkeln auf das kristall
trifft die fachleute
von lanz winkeln dazu sagt der forscher
albert lang im gegensatz zu früheren
pendelt lösungs messungen liefert unsere
technik die eigenschaften und kräfte
innerhalb des kristalls sehr präzise
einschließlich des neutronen ladungs
radius und der kräfte im nahbereich und
das trägt nicht nur zu unserem
verständnis von silizium bei sondern
auch von neutronen selbst die kräfte im
kristall können also viel viel genauer
untersucht werden vor allem die so
genannten short range kräfte haben das
interesse der physikerinnen und physiker
geweckt übersetzt also so viel wie die
kräfte im nahbereich oder so viel wie
kurzstrecken kräfte denn genau die
könnten möglicherweise wohl in
zusammenhang mit der unentdeckten kraft
stehen die manche fachleute mit der
dunklen energie in zusammenhang bringen
diese kraft könnte also möglicherweise
die antwort auf die drängendsten fragen
der modernen physik liefert die neue
studie dreht sich zudem auch um nicht
ganz neutralen neutronen in der
fachsprache ist vom sogenannten
neutronen ladungs radius die rede ist es
wirklich unglaublich wie genau das neue
verfahren ist neutronen sollten ja
eigentlich elektrisch neutral sein
zusammengesetzt sind sie aus drei
geladenen teilchen den quarks die
jeweils unterschiedliche elektrische
eigenschaften mit sich bringen die
positive netto ladung befindet sich eher
im zentrum während sich die überwiegend
negative ladung im äußeren teil des
neutrons befindet der abstand dazwischen
wird als ladungs radius bezeichnet im
aktuellen experiment kann man diesen
ladungs rates jetzt mit bisher nicht
gekannter genauigkeit untersuchen wenn
sich das neutronen im kristall befindet
befindet es sich gut innerhalb der
elektrischen atomwolke so einer der
beteiligten physiker benjamin kock das
ergebnis überrascht und sogar die
fachleute selbst die neutronen
wechselwirken fast vollständig mit den
protonen und neutronen ihnen den zentren
über kern der atome wir haben beweise
dafür gefunden dass die kerne und
elektronen möglicherweise nicht stark
schwingen wie allgemein angenommen wird
das verändert unser verständnis darüber
wie silizium atome innerhalb eines
kristall gibt das miteinander
wechselwirken sprich in diesem fall
passieren im inneren von atom vollkommen
andere dinge als bisher angenommen wow
das ist mein blowing die fachleute
planen weitere experimente mit silizium
germanium um weitere messunsicherheiten
auszuschließen so könnte vielleicht
wirklich die mysteriöse fünfte kraft der
physik schon bald entdeckt werden es ist
unglaublich was in der teilchenphysik im
moment für entdeckungen gemacht werden
neues teilchen entdeckt bisher
unbekannter materiezustand auch eine
ziemlich verblüffende entdeckung also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
auf jeden fall auf den abo button hier
oder unter jedem anderen video klicken
bis dann bleibt dran